military members and we covered this on
on human events daily just today that
there's an e4 in the air force saying
look i don't want to take this i'm about
to be kicked out i've signed up i've
gone through all my training here are my
qualifications can you guys help me find
a job right so we're purging our
military on the basis of this think
about who we're purging by the way are
health care workers so many they're in
new york state they're talking about
bringing in the national guard to
backfill health care workers i'm sorry i
thought this whole thing was supposed to
be help remember two weeks to stop the
spread right
lower the curve so that we can help icus
because of the capacity and because of
bringing the burden down on health care
workers if this is about health why are
you firing the healthcare workers
where do you grade this thing at the
moment i mean just as we're starting
this biden just said that 98 of us have
to be vaccinated otherwise we'll never
get back to normal as he was getting his
booster shot from the vaccine that he
said if you got in the first place that
you know we'd all be okay with
yeah that's actually right and and i'll
i'll break a little news on here um and
i'll hold this back week from uh you
know from twitter and everything else
before before we can do this because
actually just as you and i were
preparing to get on here in the pre-show
i got a text in from someone who is a
currently serving u.s official at the
white house who said that statement that
number that 98 came from a briefing from
dr fauci about a week ago that was being
had and my question is if i would go
back to that briefing and i'll respond
to them after this and say
it was that talking about herd immunity
because i remember the last time i heard
this herd immunity was like 75 80
was the idea and that also that herd
immunity should include people like
myself who have natural immunity because
i had real covid i had like knocked me
on my butt i'm eating vietnamese pho for
a week and watching like bad tv shows
because my you know i'm just like half
tired half asleep the whole time i mean
it sucked like it's definitely not the
flu right um but you know i i ate fun
and a bunch of like sprite and i'm fine
right i'm totally fine it's like a year
ago
and so i've still yet to have somebody
come to me and make the convincing
argument as to why natural immunity
shouldn't count right and i think
there's a huge portion of the population
that is also wondering wondering about
this plus you also used to have and
glenn greenwald talked about this that
the aclu used to be one of the leading
organizations talking against
vaccine mandates because they actually
pointed out that fact that pushing
vaccine mandates from a higher level
actually drives vaccine hesitancy
because what is it right it's the hammer
not the it's not the hammer not the
carrot right it's it's it's the same
it's your you're demanding people do it
so you're going to initiate you know
there's going to be a certain number of
people that say well i'm not going to do
it just because you say i have to why
should i right you know and it's
of course the u.s government hasn't ever
done anything dave that would call into
question their trustworthiness and their
veracity with the american people
i've never heard of anything i don't
know what you could possibly no no i
couldn't possibly it couldn't pass with
you but are you somewhat shocked that if
if we were to question any of this stuff
like i'm very aware of this on twitter
if we're to question any the veracity of
the vaccine whether it's working or not
actually as you know because i think you
were the probably the first guy i texted
the day before i went off the grid
last day of july
again what was the tweet well in essence
i said that vaccine mandates are coming
and they don't want you to know that
and and i was banned from twitter
twitter later said it was an error but
i'm pretty sure i got that one right um
but
this this is like a month ago right this
is hilarious it was it was july 31st
yeah a couple months ago okay
yeah give or take a month yeah um so you
tweet out that you think essentially it
looks like vaccine mandates are coming
banned on twitter right right locked out
was it 12 hours
12 hours and then i had to delete the
tweet otherwise they put you in they put
you in perpetual with no answer as to
when you might come back if you're
refusing to leave penalty box for 12
hours then they take you make you take
the tweet down which which by the way
you know we're talking about communism
in the book but this is
in mao's china the idea of
self-incrimination right is big right
they could delete the tweet for you
right i always bring this up with people
they could delete the tweet for you but
as part of your struggle session you
have to admit your crime you have to
admit your thought crime you know you
have to admit i was a capitalist i was
an exploitative landlord i spoke out
against the great leap forward right you
have to admit that and only if you
believe to your struggle session this is
this is the key people understand they
use that phrase struggle session you're
not struggling against the people you're
struggling against your past self and
the idea that you're purifying yourself
into the new ideology so i always think
about that when they make you delete the
tweet yourself there's something very
insidious
about that and the fact that it actually
is a form of making you incriminate your
own thoughts and your own words but the
fact is that you said this was coming
and i remember the tweet the way you had
worded it was like you think this is
coming not like you know i can prove
this is coming and yet
here we are talking about 98 percent
people are about to be kicked out of the
military there's that
in the great account libs of tick tock
um has and they're not just doing libs
anymore it's really just sort of like a
tick tock news kind of site now uh and
military members and we covered this on
on human events daily just today that
there's an e4 in the air force saying
look i don't want to take this i'm about
to be kicked out i've signed up i've
gone through all my training here are my
qualifications can you guys help me find
a job right so we're purging our
military on the basis of this think
about who we're purging by the way our
health care workers so many they're in
new york state they're talking about
bringing in the national guard to
backfill health care workers i'm sorry i
thought this whole thing was supposed to
be help remember two weeks to stop the
spread right lower the curve so that we
can help icus because of the capacity
and because of bringing the burden down
on health care workers if this is about
health why are you firing the health
care workers right so it literally we
went in a year and a half we went from
two weeks to flatten the curve to we're
firing nurses in the name of health
which i don't know that we've had any
sort of mass outbreak by nurses or
within our military or anything like
that but but what what do you think this
really gets to in that it's not stopping
i mean this is what i'm trying to
explain to people it doesn't matter if
everyone's vaccinated or everyone stays
home or everyone wears masks the
governments and i mean governments not
just ours but australia canada i mean
we're just watching western governments
commit harry carey and take down their
people at the same time that's what it
seems like to me that they they're just
loving rampaging through everyone's
rights and very few of us are doing
anything
this will
stop
when
the citizenry
decides it should stop um
you know russ dohat in the new york
times and i don't really cite the new
york times very often but he had a
pretty provocative headline on an op-ed
about a week ago and he said what if
kovid was was 10 times more deadly right
what if kovid was 10 times more deadly
and i'm like well if kovid was 10 times
more deadly that i'd probably be on
board with a lot of this stuff right i
think that would make sense don't give
him any good ideas jeff you know i don't
no but but here's here's what i'm
getting at here's what i'm getting at
because i'm not
i i want to make a point is is that
we have a situation where we know that
it's not we know that there are people
it's it's look it's been what a year and
a half i was one of the first people
that said you know all the way back
january 2020 let's add china to the
travel ban we can't allow those flights
to come in why are we still doing this
we can see what's going on in wuhan we
can see they're trying to shut it down
just stop the flights just do it just
stop the flights um we were doing
podcasts about it back then they're like
oh you're crazy you're xenophobic etc
etc said no it's about a virus that
comes from there i don't care that it is
there but it is to deal with it um we
know everything that's come out since
then about that and the lab and what
they don't want us to know et cetera et
cetera but
i think the key thing
in this is that you have a situation now
where people are going to say look
we can look at this as as independent
critical thinking individuals and know
that okay people with comorbidities you
got to take care of them people who are
seniors right they're higher at risk you
got to take care of them people who have
the immunodeficiency i i was just down
in florida
meeting with a friend of mine who had
gone through um he's had he's just
getting over throat cancer right he's
he's walks around double mast all the
time that makes sense right because he
gets that he's done he's gonna be wiped
out like his system will not be able to
handle that right that makes sense for
his position but the idea that we are
going to allow government to have all
this power
they're never going to give it away and
you know there are some people who said
well you know i think this is just it's
a one-time thing it's gotten
yeah
medical tyranny medical tyranny is the
future
right this is never going to stop
because medicine in our technology our
biotechnology is only getting better and
better our government systems are only
becoming more and more advanced you're
seeing the union now of government with
silicon valley so with technology you
tie in the biomedical aspect of that and
look if you ever watch that movie
gattaca from 1997 it's happening man
five years ago
i think it was it was andrew nichols and
ethan hawk and jude law and um thurman
and i think they just nailed it you have
two classes of people you have the
valids and the invalids and we are
rapidly very rapidly running to a
society like that if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell